>>
TREY: JOINING US NOW FARMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY,
CO-HOST OF OUT NUMBERED.
AUTHOR OF A NEW BOOK.
FOR SUCH A TIME AS THIS,
KAYLEIGH McENANY.
I'M ASKING BUT YOUR BOOK --
MY MOM AND I -- I THINK THAT
COMES FROM THE BIBLE.
>> YES.
>> BEFORE WE GET TO THAT.
I DON'T MIND TOUGH
QUESTIONS, I JUST WANT THEM
TO BE ASKED OF BOTH SIDES
WITH SAME FREQUENCY.
WHAT WAS YOUR EXPERIENCE.
>> IT WAS NOT BAD, I TRIED
TO CLEAR MY MIND OF WHAT I
KNEW ABOUT MEDIA, I CAME
FROM THE CAMPAIGN, I ALREADY
NEW MEDIA WAS NOT FAIR.
I AGREE WITH 56% OF
AMERICANS WHO BELIEVE
JOURNALISTS -- I WANTED TO
RESET, I WENT IN TRIED TO
HAVE A CLEAN STATE, THE
QUESTION BECAME COSTIC,
QUICKLY AND PERSONAL.
JEN PSAKI HAS BEEN ASKING
ABOUT A BITING INCIDENT WITH
WHITE HOUSE DOG AND CAT AND
AIR FORCE ONE COLOR SCHEME,
THEY DON'T SERVE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THESE ARE QUESTIONSY WOULD
NEVER ASK.
I THINK THAT A FAIR PRESS,
IS SOME WITH BETWEEN
SOFTBALL IN JEN SOCHI GETS
AND TOUGH QUESTIONS THAT I
GET.
>> YOU ARE A SMART PERSON, I
LIKE TO ASK WHY.
WHY IS THERE THIS PERCEPTION
AND OR REALITY THAT ONE SIDE
GETS TOUGHER QUESTIONS?
I THINK -- WHETHER PEOPLE
LIKE JONATHAN SWAN OR NOT HE
SEEMS TO BE A EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TOUGH
QUESTIONER.
LAY THAT ASIDE, REPUBLICANS
GET MUCH TOUGHER QUESTIONS
THAN DEMOCRATS BUT WHY?
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS.
>> LOOKING AT DONATIONS OF
JOURNALISTS, THE
PUBLICATIONS, WHO THEY GIVE
TO.
IT ALWAYS IS DEMOCRAT OVER
REPUBLICAN.
THIS IS A MEDIA THAT HAS A
LIBERAL BENT, THEY EXIST IN
CONFINES OF MANHATTAN,
LARGELY IN DC SWAMP, THEY
RARELY GET OUTSIDE OF THE
BUBBLE, I HAD PLEASURE TO
KNOW TRUMP VOTERS FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY, FROM
TEXAS, AND FLORIDA AND NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
VERY FEW REPORTERS GET THAT
OPPORTUNITY, THIS SAY
LIBERAL PROFESSION,
UNFORTUNATELY, THE QUESTIONS
DON'T SERVE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND YOU KNOW, I HOPE IT
CHANGES, WE NEED YOUNG
PEOPLE TO GO INTO
JOURNALISM, THOSE WHO ARE
EQUAL OPPORTUNIST
QUESTIONERS.
TREY: ALL RIGHT.
YOU HAVE A NEW BOOK OUT.
YOU HAVE WRITTEN MORE BOOKS
THAN I HAVE READ.
I KNOW YOU HAVE A NEW ONE.
TELL US WHAT MOTIVATED AND
INSPIRED YOU AND WHAT WE
WILL LEARN AS WE READ IT.
>> I AM A PERSON OF FAITH, I
AM A CHRISTIAN, WITH HARD
TIMES IN LIFE, AND CERTAINLY
IN WHITE HOUSE, MAY SAVIOR
SHOWED UP, I WANTED TO TALK
ABOUT MY FAITH JOURNEY FROM
A YOUNG PERSON TO THE WHITE
HOUSE, IN ADDITION TO THAT,
I DO GET INTO PRESS, THERE
IS A CHAPTER CALLED
VINDICATION WITH SO MANY
NARRATIVES THAT WE KNOW NOT
TO BE TRUE.
AND THERE WAS MANY OTHERS,
RUSSIAN BOUNTIES ON HEADS OF
AMERICAN TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN, THAT WAS NOT
TRUE, HOLD THE PRESS
ACCOUNTABLE.
I SHARE ABOUT MY FAITH AND
MY LORD AND SAVIOR, AND HOW
HE SHOWED UP WHEN THE GOING
GOT TOUGH.
>> ALL RIGHT, LET ME ASK YOU
.
THE CHALLENGE OF SOMEONE WHO
IS A BELIEVER LIKE YOU TO BE
IN THE ENVIRONMENT THAT YOU
WERE IN, DID IT STRENGTHEN
YOUR FAITH OR WEAKEN YOUR
FAITH?
>> IT STRENGTHENED IT.
THERE WAS A LOT OF TEARS,
BEFORE I FIRST TOOK TO
PODIUM, I WAS NERVOUS, BUT
WHEN YOU IN IN THOSE VALLOWS
VAL -- VALLEYS
IN LIFE, THAT IS WHAT GOD
SHOWS UP, I HEARD FROM
PRAYERS FROM MANY, FROM LEFT
AND RIGHT, WOULD SEND THE
SAME BIBLE VERSE,
FOR SUCH A TIME AS THIS.
>> FOR SUCH A TIME AS THIS.
KAYLEIGH McENANY, THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE